- First of all, can you
even take the whole thing?
You can't even take this whole thing.
It's not possible.
- Speak for yourself. (laughing)
(upbeat music)
- Large, big dicks like this
are only good in theory,
not in usage, 'cause I'm not
putting this anywhere me.
- This is too big (laughing)
If I saw this in the wild
I would say no thank you.
- But I feel like whatever size it is,
you shouldn't be shamed for it.
- Yes.
- You're beautiful either way.
- Do you know what somebody
could do with this?
- Yes.
- Damage, actual damage.
- Actual damage, literally.
- Like your organs are rearranged.
- Size does matter but it's
not the most important thing.
- How many wieners have you seen
in your lifetime do you think?
- I don't think I can count.
Not that are-- wait!
(laughing together)
Wait, wait!
- So, I guess we are
cutting this to the size
of what we think is the average penis.
- Okay, I'm gonna do five thumbs.
- I think I'm gonna get this right.
- I'm just gonna call on my spirit angels.
Wait a second.
(vinyl record screech)
Important question, is
this the penis erect?
- Yeah, that's what you just said, hard.
Flaccid, it's like just cut the tip off.
(laughing together)
- I'm gonna stand up. (laughing)
I'm just like, okay, I'm
trying to imagine the dick.
- It's already squirting juices.
- Imagine the length on length.
Are you good?
- I did it, this is my penis.
(laughing together)
- Alright, I'm going to
go ahead and say this--
- I'm gonna say this.
- Boom.
- You know.
- Hard.
- Average?
Boy, that's good.
- No, I mean like, what
I'm saying is hard though.
No, no, no, no, no, like--
- I think you're giving
these people too much credit.
So, now I'm using this
tape to add a tiny bit
'cause I cut mine I think too small.
(muted gong)
- Dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, duuuun.
- [Girl In Blue Sweater] That's big.
- [Girl In Jean Jacket] (screams)
I'm so close!
- No, okay.
- Look how close I am.
- I really overshot that.
- I knew it.
(Exclaiming together)
- That's huge.
- This is a big dick.
(laughing together)
- Oh my God, that is so, okay.
- I made ours too small.
- I don't know what that says about us.
- Five inches.
- I'm actually not surprised.
I know that most penises are like this
and then you're just
blessed if you do have
one of these little babies.
- Yeah, blessed or cursed.
- Whatever you're working with,
three inches, eight
inches, it doesn't matter,
like you should love yourself
and if you don't, I will.
- You choose the man over,
not over the penis size,
you choose it over what
kind of person they are.
So like, it really doesn't
matter what size your dick is,
it matters what kind of
a human being you are.
- Love, love is what sex is about.
- I don't know if I agree with that.
(Girl in jean jacket laughs)
There's a whole lot of sex
that has no love at all.
(whip crack and creaking sign)